DR. T: Oh, look at those
beautiful teeth you have.
NARRATOR:
Deep in the heart of Texas,
there's no such thing as
a typical patient for Dr. T,
and that includes Shiloh,
a four-year-old scarlet macaw
with an itchy predicament.
REBECCA: Shiloh got her name
because I am a big
Neil Diamond fan.
And there's a song by that name,
Shiloh, and she is my companion.
She goes with me places,
we go to elementary schools,
we go to nursing homes.
She loves that, you know,
and the people really enjoy
getting to see her.
NARRATOR: But lately,
Shiloh isn't acting
like her usual, happy self.
REBECCA: She just spends most of
her time pulling at her feathers
or preening her feathers,
which she's doing with her beak,
and she's damaging them.
There must be
an underlying issue
and that's why I brought her
here today.
DR. T: Hi. I'm Dr. Thielen,
nice to meet you.
Hey, pretty girl.
You are gorgeous.
So, tell me exactly
where she's picking,
and can you even
show me with her,
I don't have to touch her yet.
REBECCA: This is where
she's been picking, looks like.
Right at the base of where
her tail meets the body.
DR. T: That's the only spot,
though?
Oh, okay.
REBECCA: What she's aiming at,
what she's trying to get...
DR. T: Is the feather shaft.
REBECCA: Yes.
And they're bloody.
And that's what's worrying me.
DR. T: I agree.
Preening is the behavior that
a bird does to groom themselves.
In Shiloh's case,
she's taking it to the extreme
and we need to figure out
why that is.
How often does she bathe?
REBECCA: That's the other thing.
She won't come near me for days
if I take her to the shower.
DR. T: Oh.
REBECCA: And I've actually taken
her and put her on my chest
with a T-shirt on in the shower,
and she just gets that,
she's just quaking
and does that "uhrrrr."
DR. T: If Shiloh's not bathing,
it can be a serious problem,
because, in parrots,
baths are pretty necessary
in order to keep their skin
and feathers clean and healthy.
Otherwise, dirt and dander can
build up and trigger anything
from abnormal preening
to even infections.
She is preening a lot.
REBECCA: Oh, yeah,
it's just constant.
DR. T: Does she do that
at home this much?
I mean, my bird preens,
but jeez,
I mean, she hasn't stopped
since we've been here.
REBECCA: No, uh-uh.
But she'll just sit there
and do that for hours.
I try to divert her attention,
I get, you know, nuts for her,
she loves pine nuts, and I'll
give her three or four of those.
DR. T: Yeah, she's like obsessed
with it, is what's happening.
Not even just her tail,
that's what she's doing
the most damage to,
but just preening in general.
She just seems very agitated.
REBECCA: She is.
DR. T: Is she going
to let me hold her?
REBECCA: Well, she may.
DR. T: I'll just see.
Hi, pretty girl.
You gonna go onto me?
Want to come up? Good girl!
What a good bird, sweetheart.
Your momma's right here.
Are you just beautiful?
Look at your orange cheeks.
Your orange cheeks
are so pretty.
Can I pet you? Yeah?
Oh, oh, oh. Yes, you're
a good girl, aren't you?
Seeing Shiloh this uncomfortable
and in obvious distress
is painful for me, so I can only
imagine what Shiloh feels like.
I'm a bird mom, too,
and I know if this was my bird,
I'd do whatever it takes to make
her happy and healthy again.
So I'm definitely going do
everything I can to help Shiloh.
These feathers
don't look healthy, though.
Do you see them,
how they're black?
And they just look brittle
and not normal.
REBECCA: Because of
the not bathing?
DR. T: Maybe.
Parrots in general are
these highly intelligent,
extremely social beings
who can have a lot of problems
in captivity.
Oftentimes there's some
kind of anxiety going on
that causes them to over-preen.
Because those feathers
just don't look normal,
I'm actually thinking that
her preening all the time
isn't psychogenic,
there actually may be
an underlying medical cause.
I definitely want to do
a basic medical work-up,
but I do have some things in
mind that I want to test for,
that would mainly involve
her skin and feathers.
NARRATOR: For Shiloh's safety
and comfort,
Dr. T gives her a sedative.
(squawk)
MARYANNE: In the muscle.
TONYA: Go sleepy.
NARRATOR: Takes a blood sample.
MARYANNE: There you go.
NARRATOR: A feather.
DR. T: One, two.
(Maryanne gasps)
I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
NARRATOR: And a slide
impression of Shiloh's skin
will be submitted for testing.
DR. T: Now it's just
a waiting game.
We are sending everything off
and we're just gonna wait
on results to make a plan.
NARRATOR: Just down the hall
is Tex Rex,
a four-year-old bearded dragon
with an appetite for disaster.
Thankfully, Dr. Bruce Nixon
is here to help.
DR. NIXON: Hi, I'm Dr. Nixon,
how are you doing?
KELLI: Hi. Hi, good,
how are you?
DR. NIXON: So, I hear that
you have a dragon
who thinks he's a coin purse?
KELLI: Yes.
While I was out to dinner,
I get a hysterical call
from my 13-year-old son.
He walked in his room and
he threw his wallet on the bed
and a couple of coins fell out.
Rex is walking around,
and he goes, all of a sudden,
he just saw that penny and
he went over and ate it,
before he could do
anything about it.
DR. NIXON: Hello, Rex.
I know.
Pennies are actually
made of zinc,
and zinc causes
a heavy metal toxicosis, okay?
And this can really
make them ill.
NARRATOR: Heavy metal toxicosis
can damage internal organs,
trigger anemia and
even cause death.
There's no time to wait.
The penny must come out now.
DR. NIXON: We're gonna do this
step by step.
First of all, we want to make
sure that it's really in there.
That's easy, we're gonna get
an x-ray taken.
KELLI: Okay.
DR. NIXON: Okay?
DR. NIXON: Then what
we're going to do
is we're going to
anesthetize him briefly
and what we're probably gonna do
is use what's called
a rigid endoscope, okay,
to actually go in
under anesthesia,
through the mouth
and into the stomach
and we can probably get this out
without doing surgery.
KELLI: That was our hope,
that hopefully it could be
removed without surgery.
DR. NIXON: If you'll let me
borrow him for a minute
and we'll take a quick x-ray
and we'll make sure
that it's in there, okay?
KELLI: Okay.
My son loves this dragon so
much, Tex Rex, he's his buddy.
He's been texting me all day
from school.
He is beside himself with worry
and I think he feels
very responsible.
DR. NIXON:
Get a radiograph on him.
JACOB: No problem.
KELLI: And I know my son
would be very, very worried
if he had to have surgery.
JACOB: Oh, there it is.
NARRATOR: Tex Rex's x-ray
results are beyond conclusive.
DR. NIXON: No, there's the
Lincoln Memorial right there.
We've definitely got it in here,
so what we need to do now
is to prepare for some
endoscopic retrieval.
NARRATOR: Dr. Nixon drafts
Dr. T to be his right-hand vet.
DR. NIXON: We're gonna do good.
DR. T: Yay! I'm so excited.
As a vet, there's no such thing
as knowing too much,
and one of the things
I love most about my job
is that I'm always
learning more.
And I get to collaborate with
other amazingly talented vets,
like Dr. Nixon, who has a ton
of knowledge and experience.
So not only does that
benefit me,
it benefits all
our patients, too.
DR. NIXON: Open.
NARRATOR: As soon as
the anesthesia kicks in,
it's time for Dr. Nixon
and Dr. T to get to work.
DR. T: Okay.
We're choosing endoscopy
instead of a surgery
because it's much less invasive,
there's no surgery that
the animal needs to heal from,
and if the penny
went in that way,
it means it should be able
to come out that way.
Going down the esophagus.
DR. NIXON: Esophagus.
We're going to go
into the stomach
and actually visually
see that penny,
and this is where
Dr. Thielen and I
are gonna be working in concert.
So she's going to
locate the penny
and she's gonna hold it steady,
and then I'm gonna come in
right behind her
and I'm gonna grab the penny,
which means that I will get
all of the glory.
So, this should work
marvelously.
NARRATOR: Next door, Molly,
a newly adopted
Flemish giant rabbit,
lands in the ER,
and she's in dire straits.
MAIKE: We've only had her
at home for three days.
The person at the rescue
said that the owners
could no longer afford her care.
DEREK: So, we flew to California
and then we brought her back.
MAIKE: She was just
recently spayed,
but other than that,
she seemed in good shape.
But then we noticed
that she was bleeding,
and so we checked her belly
and we saw that some big thing
was sticking out
of her incision.
MAIKE: And so we just rushed her
here as soon as we noticed,
because we were scared she was
gonna die on the drive.
DR. FREEMAN: Oh, jeez.
DR. FREEMAN: She actually
started chewing on her incision,
so her urinary bladder is
sticking out of her abdomen.
We need to figure out a way to
put it back in and stabilize her
until Dr. Thielen can see her.
NARRATOR: Molly's condition
is so serious,
even the ER hospital's Chief
of Medicine steps in to help.
DR. TURNER: This is shocking.
We don't typically see
animals come in
with their bladders
outside their body.
DR. TURNER:
That makes me a little worried
that might be the ureter.
One of her ureters
is bruised and inflamed
and possibly damaged.
DR. FREEMAN: So there's a little
bit of ulcerations right here.
DR. TURNER: This is
a huge problem,
because the ureter is what
allows urine to be transported
from the kidney to the bladder,
and a damaged ureter can lead
to kidney failure,
as well as a number
of other complications.
Let's get this cleaned up,
get that bladder back in
as quickly as possible,
'cause we don't want impingement
on that second ureter.
DR. FREEMAN: Yeah, okay.
DR. TURNER: Molly's bladder
is so inflamed
that it is not fitting back
through her tiny spay incision
that had opened up.
The bladder's not going
back in the hole.
DR. FREEMAN: Yeah.
DR. TURNER: Which was
sort of the easy way.
DR. FREEMAN: Yeah.
DR. TURNER: So at the very least
we're gonna have to extend
that incision, flush the belly,
we're worried about the ureter,
the kidney may have to go.
We are gonna need to get her
into the surgery suite
so we can extend this incision,
get a better look at what
possible damage has occurred
in her body and get this bladder
back in as soon as we can.
NARRATOR: Molly is
given anesthesia
and prepped for surgery.
HAYLEY: Hey, we need
for a doctor in here now!
Freeman, it's your bunny on CPR.
DR. TURNER: What is the issue?
What is the issue?
HAYLEY: Stopped breathing.
DR. TURNER: Okay.
NARRATOR: Molly, the Flemish
giant rabbit's bladder
is completely outside
of her body,
and she needs emergency surgery
to get it back in.
But before surgery even begins,
her condition takes
a critical nosedive.
DR. TURNER: Go ahead and
give this half IV, half IM.
We don't usually give it IV,
but we're going to have
to make an exception.
Molly has flat-lined on us after
we gave her the medications
to induce anesthesia.
We are working quickly
to try and get her back.
We lost heart and the rabbit
stopped breathing
and we did get
a heartbeat back.
Have we taken any spontaneous
breaths at this point?
Okay.
These owners literally just got
this rabbit within the week.
They went all the way to
California for this bunny,
so this is a big deal to them,
and even in the short period of
time, we've all gotten attached,
so it's a big deal to us.
DR. TURNER: Thankfully,
Molly has responded
and is more stable,
so we need to get in there,
get that bladder back in and
get her sewed up right now.
NARRATOR: But within minutes,
Molly's heart rate
plunges again.
DR. TURNER: Do you have
femoral pulse?
DR. TURNER: Molly's heart rate
has dropped on us again.
I am really worried she's going
to arrest on us a second time,
but Molly is not
going to survive
unless we get this bladder
back in,
so we are going to move forward
as quickly as possible,
open that incision,
get the bladder back in,
and then hopefully get her more
stable to see Dr. Thielen.
How much has her heart rate
slowed down, anybody?
TONYA: Quite a bit.
DR. TURNER: What number?
Did she have a heartbeat?
TONYA: Yes, she has
a heartbeat.
NARRATOR: Dr. Turner swiftly
extends Molly's spay incision
and inserts her bladder
back inside her body.
NARRATOR: And for now, Molly's
close brush with death
appears to be behind her.
DR. FREEMAN: There you go.
KIM: There you go.
DR. FREEMAN: Wake up. Hi!
HAYLEY: Hey, Molly.
KIM: Oh, that's better.
DR. FREEMAN: Hey, Molly.
HAYLEY: Hi! Yeah, hi.
DR. TURNER: We don't always see
these guys survive to discharge,
but sometimes what we have to
focus in on is the teamwork
and the small wins,
and this was a really good
example of teamwork
and at least a small step
in the right direction, so.
Good job, everybody.
DR. FREEMAN: Good job.
DR. TURNER: Molly is far from
out of the woods at this point.
We are going to hopefully
get her more stable
and then we can transfer
the rabbit's care
to Dr. Thielen's practice
completely.
NARRATOR: Molly has made it
through her surgery,
but Tex Rex is still
stomach-deep in his endoscopy.
DR. T: I see that brown thing,
but that's not a penny.
What is that? Food?
DR. NIXON: Poke it.
DR. T: It's gotta be food.
DR. NIXON: Well, unfortunately
it had a meal
right before it ate the penny.
NARRATOR: Tex Rex has
a potentially toxic penny
in his stomach that needs
to come out immediately.
But this penny is
playing hard to get.
DR. T: So, I'm trying
to find this penny
in this sea of
bearded dragon food,
and it's just, oh, my god,
this is a frustrating nightmare.
DR. NIXON: The thing that
is complicating matters
is all of the food
that's in the stomach.
If it was just a penny,
this would be a piece of cake,
but all the food is
getting in the way.
DR. T: With the endoscopy, we
always have to just keep in mind
that this camera is not only
really magnified,
but every movement,
every little tiny movement
is a really big movement
on the screen.
DR. NIXON: Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
DR. T: Oh, wait,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
So, although it's
pretty straightforward
with how you have to move
the camera,
finding the penny
through all that food
is not as easy as it looks.
Where'd it go?
I just saw something.
DR. T: See, it is a mealworm.
DR. NIXON: Yeah, that is a worm.
DR. T: Oh, that is so gross.
It's like a waxworm
or something.
I think you're gonna
have to insufflate it.
So we're gonna actually
have to do insufflation.
We're gonna fill the stomach
with some water,
so that way it distends
and be able to swirl around
all the food,
so hopefully I can see the penny
with inside the stomach.
DR. NIXON: It's a salad
inside right now.
We're gonna make it a water
balloon with a salad inside.
DR. T: Okay.
When I'm doing the insufflation,
the most important thing
is that Tex Rex
doesn't accidentally inhale
some of this water,
'cause if that happens
and enough liquid
gets into his lungs,
at the very least
it's gonna cause an infection,
or it could even kill him.
So we're going to intubate him
to prevent any extra fluid
that's overfilling
from his stomach
from going down his trachea.
Okay.
DR. NIXON: That's much better.
DR. T: Yes.
Just still watch the tube.
Okay, so now we go again.
The whole time we still have
to keep in mind, though,
that we're inside
a really sensitive organ,
so you want to be really careful
and not too rough.
DR. NIXON: Is that it
right there?
DR. T: That's your mealworm.
DR. NIXON:
Oh, that is a mealworm.
DR. T: That's as far as it goes.
DR. NIXON: Okay.
DR. T: I'm just not
seeing the penny.
Everything but
the frickin' penny.
DR. NIXON: No kidding.
There it is!
DR. T: (gasps) There it is,
there it is, there it is.
Don't move, don't move,
don't move.
DR. NIXON: Instrument.
DR. T: Grabbers.
DR. NIXON: Got it.
Everybody just be still.
DR. T: I'm gonna advance you.
Open.
Oh, (bleep), I can't see it.
Where'd it go?
Oh, no, where'd it go?
DR. T: Where'd it go?
NARRATOR: A four-year-old
bearded dragon, Tex Rex,
has a potentially toxic penny
inside his stomach,
and Dr. T and Dr. Nixon are
on a mission to find it
and get it out.
But a belly full of food
is foiling their plans.
DR. NIXON: We can see the salad,
we can see the worms.
Okay, let's do this.
Take everything out
and now let's palpate.
DR. T: We're not having
great success
with our endoscopy exploration.
So, desperate times call
for desperate measures.
We're gonna have
to try something else.
NARRATOR: Dr. Nixon physically
locates the penny.
DR. NIXON: I'm holding the penny
in my fingers.
DR. T: You're holding
the penny in your fingers.
DR. NIXON: Mm-hm, yep, I am.
DR. T: Well, hang on, then,
let me find it.
I'm thinking that, since I have
a pretty good idea
of where the penny is
in the stomach,
if I can get an instrument
really carefully
down into the stomach,
I might be able to feel that
metal on metal sensation,
be able to find the penny
and pull it out.
Ready? Ready?
DR. NIXON: Yeah.
DR. T: Whaaaaaa!!
(laughs)
Oh, my god!
That was insane!
It's a 2002 Abe Lincoln.
DR. NIXON: Superstars.
DR. T: This is amazing.
We were in there with
our big, fancy equipment
and all you needed was
a pair of forceps
and go down the bearded dragon,
and there's your penny.
(laughs)
DR. NIXON: That does not
belong to us,
that belongs to the client.
NARRATOR: Tex Rex is now
penny-free and free to go home.
DR. NIXON: Look who I have.
KELLI: Aw, there he is.
He's probably glad to see you.
DR. NIXON: Now you can tell
all your friends
that your bearded dragon
is now penniless, he's poor.
KELLI: Here's the penny,
and it looks just like it did
on the x-ray.
DR. NIXON: It wasn't in there
long enough
to cause any kind
of zinc toxicosis,
so this should be the end of it.
KELLI: Ben's gonna decide
what he wants to do with it.
Make jewelry or frame it.
BENJAMIN: Frame it.
KELLI: He can't eat it if it's
in a frame on the wall. Right?
BENJAMIN: Mm-hmm.
♪ ♪
DR. T: Hi, sweet girl.
NARRATOR: With Tex Rex
out the door and on the mend,
Molly, the Flemish
giant rabbit,
is transferred from the ER
to Dr. T's care.
DR. T: Wow.
MARYANNE: Well otherwise.
DR. T: She's not painful there,
which is good.
Good. Good girl.
Can I feel your belly, too, hmm?
Oh, she's so cute.
I understand why they went
all the way to California
for seeing her now.
She is gorgeous.
I'm so relieved that the ER
was able to save Molly's life.
She's such a sweet rabbit
who's been through a lot.
I mean, she just arrived
in Texas a few days ago,
barely had any time to get
settled with her family
and now this?
I really want to take
good care of her.
I'm surprised
she looks this good
after, you know, dying
and being revived.
She's quiet, obviously,
but what's her temp?
MARYANNE: It's been high.
She was 105 next door.
DR. T: Okay, let's keep
an eye on that.
Molly does have quite
a high fever, it's 105 degrees.
For a rabbit, it should be
anywhere between 101 and 103.5,
and so it being that high
is concerning.
I'm thinking there's
an infection brewing somewhere
that we really need
to get a hold of.
NARRATOR: And Dr. T detects
another issue, too.
DR. T: Oh, dear. Well, honey.
I know, sweetheart.
As I'm starting
to examine Molly,
I'm seeing this abscess
that she has.
It's right beneath her eye,
and may be not so noticeable
at first
because the fur is
kind of stuck to the pus,
and it's, like, covering it.
But it's quite large, it's
oozing and it stinks horribly.
At some point it would be nice
to clip and clean that thing.
It's just I haven't wanted
to stress her out yet.
MARYANNE: Okay, well,
let's just let her relax, then.
After she gets morphine,
she's good to chill.
DR. T: My plan for Molly at this
point is just oversee her care,
get some more fluids into her,
make sure her fever is
getting controlled,
that she's comfortable,
that she's recovering from this
super-crazy, traumatic event
that just happened.
Her condition is just
so fragile,
I really want to take
this step by step.
NARRATOR: Molly receives
a nutrient-dense,
high-fiber formula, designed
especially for herbivores
recovering from surgery
or illness.
TONYA: You're being sassy,
so I mean, that's good at least.
NARRATOR: And then she gets
a much-needed dose of love
from her devoted parents.
MARYANNE: She's got
a little cone of shame on
so she doesn't re-open
her belly again.
MAIKE: Hi, Molly.
MARYANNE: Let me get you
a towel to put her on.
MAIKE: I was so happy
to see her.
It's crazy how little time it
takes to start missing a bunny.
And we've only had her
at home for three days
and I've missed her so much.
DEREK: I just want
to pick her up
and just, like,
give her a big hug.
DR. T: She is so special.
NARRATOR: Dr. T joins them with
an update on Molly's condition.
DR. T: She is doing okay,
honestly.
We just have a little bit
of problems with her fever.
The fever can come from
three different places.
So the abscess is
the source of infection
that we'll need to address,
but not today.
We have the collar on her so she
doesn't pick at herself again,
but while y'all are visiting,
we can take it off
and you can look at
her beautiful face.
MAIKE: We have four bunnies
at home already.
DEREK: She fit right in.
All the bunnies loved her.
So Molly is meant to be
with our pack, I guess,
and I hope that
we can take her home.
But if she has to stay longer,
then that's okay, too,
as long as she gets better.
DR. T: The thing that I'm really
worried about, though,
the very, very most,
is her ureter,
which is the tube that connects
the kidney to the bladder.
And the comment was,
when she had the bladder out,
was that it was really red
and looked compromised.
And so, worst-case scenario
that happens in that situation
is I'll have to remove
the kidney.
DEREK: So if worse
comes to worst
and you have to remove a kidney,
does that increase the
likelihood of the other one...
DR. T: The only thing it does
is if the other one
does have a problem,
then we only have one kidney.
I can't remove that one, too.
That's the only problem.
But actually, no, it doesn't
increase the chances
that something bad's gonna
happen to the other kidney.
DEREK: Okay, cool.
DR. T: Which is cool.
DR. T: Yeah. Thank goodness.
I've had bunnies live,
like, completely normal lives
with one.
And the good news is,
is, like, we have time,
'cause the other kidney is
functioning and she's urinating.
Considering everything,
I'm happy where we're at.
I just don't want to be lax.
So she's definitely needs
to stay with me today,
and then I will send her back
to the ER overnight
for them to just monitor her
and then she'll come back to me.
And then we'll see
how she looks.
She may be able to go home
end of the day tomorrow,
she may need one more day.
MAIKE: Okay.
We hope to come back tomorrow
to take her home
and then hopefully she won't
have to stay overnight again.
We hope to kind of
start providing
some stability for her.
She's been kind of been handed
around, first from her owners,
then she was at the vet
and then she got spayed,
and then she had to fly with us,
and I really think she needs
some quiet and
some stability now.
DEREK: Honestly, I just hope
that she turns out okay.
MAIKE: Okay, Miss Molly,
are you gonna be okay?
DR. T: Alright, Moll.
Little big bunny.
Okay, I'll take
really good care of her.
Molly, she's still critical.
She has this persistent fever
which I'm afraid
if we don't get it under
control, she could decline.
I'm going to the ER, Mary.
MARY: Okay.
DR. T: She's in way too fragile
of a state right now
to be left alone
without 24-hour monitoring.
Any of our patients that require
overnight monitoring,
like in Molly's case,
we transfer them to the ER
so that way they can get
the care they need.
Hi, here's your bunny.
KIM: Hi, Molly.
DR. T: And I really want Molly
to have a happy ending,
so I'm gonna do
whatever it takes
to make sure
everything goes well.
(moo)
(chirping)
DR. T: Hi, good morning, Molly.
NARRATOR: Molly,
the Flemish giant rabbit,
makes it through
her overnight in the ER
and celebrates with
a healthy breakfast.
Then it's back to the exam
table for a checkup with Dr. T.
DR. T: Can I look at
her incision,
just see how much she is
picking or not picking.
TONYA: And her temperature
was 103.1 this morning.
DR. T: Oh, fantastic.
TONYA: Don't be crazy.
Don't be crazy.
DR. T:
She doesn't seem like she's
doing too much damage to it.
Good girl. Good girl.
How are you, huh?
You feel better?
Urinating,
good report overnight?
TONYA: Yep.
Looks like they've recorded
some poos in her cage.
DR. T: When Molly came in,
just a little over 24 hours ago,
she was really unstable,
and she actually died
and was brought back to life
by those amazing ER doctors.
And so from dying to reviving
and having a surgery
from her bladder coming out,
I mean she couldn't look better.
NARRATOR: Molly needs
more time to heal
before she can undergo
a conclusive ultrasound check
of her bladder,
ureter and kidney.
For now, Dr. T sets her sights
on Molly's abscess.
DR. T: We really need to take
care of Molly's abscess,
but to do that effectively,
we need to determine
the underlying cause.
TONYA: Can I have
your face out, please?
DR. T: Are you gonna
let me do this?
TONYA: Maybe.
DR. T: Are you gonna be gross?
TONYA: Definitely.
DR. T: Definitely.
DR. T: At this point, though,
I'm just gonna
clean the abscess,
shave the fur around,
so we can try to just manage it,
until I can get her
to a more stable point
where I'm gonna feel
much more comfortable
in moving on with
some diagnostics.
TONYA: Okay.
DR. T: This is gonna be
the worst part.
TONYA: This is gonna
be the worst part.
DR. T: It's gonna feel
much better after, okay.
TONYA: Okay.
DR. T: Close your eyes,
don't look.
Why am I afraid of this?
It's gonna squirt on me.
(laughs)
As I'm flushing the abscess, I'm
actually pleasantly surprised.
You would think that if
it was a really big abscess
inside the bone or
even from the tooth,
that, you know, this giant hole
would have a lot of pus
ready to kind of come out.
God, I'm dying to see.
It just doesn't feel dental.
I wonder if we could just even
take x-rays of her head to see.
There's really no pus
flushing out of this,
which makes me kind of think
maybe this is more of
a superficial skin abscess
versus actually
a bone infection,
which, I mean, the prognosis
is drastically different.
Well, let her relax
and that's all I can feasibly
think to do with that.
TONYA: Okey-dokey.
DR. T: But at least it's shaved
so it won't, like, collect
any more pus on her fur.
But I am still concerned about
the condition of her ureter
and if she's gonna have
any long-term damage
with that or her kidney.
And I still have to figure out
what's going on with her abscess
and get that treated.
So she's not in the clear yet.
But I'm gonna go ahead and
send Molly home for the weekend.
She's stable enough now that I
think going home with her family
is gonna be the best thing
for her.
Hey.
Okay, sweetheart.
Alright, go feel better.
If this gets gross, you can wipe
it with some dilute iodine.
You just mix a couple drops
of iodine with some warm water
so it looks like iced tea color.
DEREK: We're really glad that
Dr. Thielen saw Molly.
She took really good
care of her.
So I guess, until Monday we're
just gonna relax on the weekend
and just chill together.
DR. T: Oh, he's tiny!
KIM: I know.
DR. T: (gasps) Hi, teenager.
KIM: They're supposedly
15 weeks out of pouch.
NARRATOR: Next up,
two furry faces are here
to meet Dr. T for
the very first time.
DR. T: I have Bandit
and Boomer here,
who are two really young,
adorable little sugar gliders.
They're here just for
their first wellness exam
and to talk about
getting neutered.
Oh, they're darling.
So, which one's which?
KIM: Bandit's the darker one
and Boomer is the lighter one.
Yeah. He looks like a Bandit.
DR. T: Don't you nibble.
KIM: Boomer is a lot more
laidback than Bandit.
Boomer will just find a place
to just hang out and chill,
which is usually on my shoulder
or my daughter's shoulder.
Bandit loves to run around
and check things out.
I don't know if they're
brothers or not.
They were rehomed to me after
the people only had 'em
for, like, a week and a half.
There was a lady that was
trying to rehome two babies
that her husband
and her two sons
had bought at a reptile show.
She said they didn't
have time for 'em,
so I offered to take them
and here we are.
DR. T: Alright, Boom,
how are you?
Let's look at you, huh?
KIM: So, yeah,
I wanted to come in
'cause I need to get
these two fixed
before I put 'em
with my other, yes.
DR. T: With your females?
I understand.
KIM: Yes, yes.
DR. T: Oh, I lost it.
KIM: We don't want any babies.
I don't want them to breed
with my adult females.
They're already over-bred
as it is.
So I just,
I don't want any babies.
DR. T: This is the stethoscope.
It's okay, want to smell?
I really like working
with sugar gliders.
They're just adorable!
They have like the biggest eyes
and they're so soft.
They're just one
of the cutest animals
I think that could
possibly exist.
NARRATOR: Boomer didn't seem
to mind his exam.
But Bandit is another story.
(screeching)
DR. T: No way.
Tell me about it.
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry.
(laughs)
(screeching)
Okay, dude, I'm sorry.
Whoo!
It's like a skunk.
Do you smell that?
NARRATOR: Male sugar gliders
use three scent glands
to mark territory, but if
they're nervous or scared,
their naturally sweet, musky
scent can easily turn sour.
DR. T: I know they had
scent glands;
I just didn't expect them
to actually smell like that.
Because I've pissed off
a lot of sugar gliders
and I've never experienced
that smell.
NARRATOR: Bandit and Boomer
passed their wellness exams
with flying colors.
But these little guys aren't
ready to be neutered just yet.
DR. T: I would wait,
just because I want them
to be an adult size.
KIM: Mm-hmm, yeah.
DR. T: It's more because
of the anesthesia.
Whenever there is
a neonate animal,
you're always pretty cautious
about anesthetizing them,
just because, you know,
they're not fully developed,
something could go wrong.
And so I always think
it's much safer to wait
till the animal's
a little bit older
to do elective procedures
on them.
So I'll see you
in, like, a month.
KIM: Okay.
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: Shiloh,
a four-year-old scarlet macaw,
has been obsessively preening
for weeks.
Now that her medical test
results are back,
Dr. T immediately detects
the reason why.
DR. T: Ooh, here. Here!
That is all yeast.
Yeah, it's all yeast.
Not normal.
It's that, that, that, that.
All the big purple splotches
is the yeast.
The skin cytology showed
that there is a lot of yeast
all over Shiloh's skin.
You may have a low level
of yeast on your skin,
but it should be nothing
compared to what I was seeing
on that microscope.
I mean, it's thick
and it's everywhere,
and I bet that's why the bird
is just constantly
itchy, itchy, itchy,
itchy, itchy.
NARRATOR: Yeast infections
are a fungal disease
and can be a common problem
for exotic birds.
Causes may include malnutrition
and poor hygiene.
DR. T: Really, the best way
for me to treat this is a bath.
The purpose of the bath is
to be able to administer
an anti-fungal shampoo,
to get it all over,
not only her skin
but also her feathers,
because if I had to guess,
this yeast is pretty much
all over her body.
The only tricky part with this
is that we already know
Shiloh doesn't like water.
NARRATOR: Bathing Shiloh
calls for backup,
so Dr. T enlists the help
of her vet tech, Maryanne.
DR. T: So I was thinking,
you and I bathe her.
MARYANNE: Like, it's like
a one-time thing?
DR. T: Today.
The only problem is,
she doesn't sedate,
and I do not know if she's gonna
let us do this awake.
The tricky part with this
is that yesterday
when I tried to sedate her,
she really did not go to sleep.
I really don't know how I'm
gonna accomplish it without...
MARYANNE: She's gonna
freak out and panic.
It's not gonna go well.
(squawking)
NARRATOR: Shiloh, the scarlet
macaw, needs a medicated bath
to treat the nasty
fungal yeast infection
that's driving her
to obsessively preen.
But there's a big hitch.
Shiloh hates baths,
and on top of that, she doesn't
sedate easily, either.
DR. T: Just like in people,
different individuals and
animals have different responses
to medications,
and in Shiloh's case,
she's not really seeming to get
very sedated with my drugs.
However, she's relaxed enough,
and I don't want to give her
any more at this point.
(squawking)
Getting it underneath that wing,
getting it on all the feathers.
I'm so sorry, Shiloh.
Is it good?
You're okay, sweetie?
(squawk)
Don't know if that was
a yes or a no.
It was a something.
(squawk)
Birds do not need soap
in their baths,
they just need water baths,
unless your bird has
a yeast infection.
That's why we use sedation,
'cause this is very abnormal
to happen for a bird.
Let's get your skin
on your feet, too, huh?
Maybe it's on there.
We don't know where it's at.
It's everywhere.
(squawk) I know!
It does look pretty cute.
(squawk) I know.
It looks so cute.
Hopefully she'll just feel
a lot better after this
because her skin
won't be as itchy.
Good girl!
Let's ring you out.
MARYANNE: Want to do her neck?
(squawk)
DR. T: We very well may need
to continue bathing her,
maybe even weekly.
However, I want to do at least
this initial bath today,
put her on an oral anti-fungal
and then see if that helps.
NARRATOR: For her comfort,
Shiloh is transferred
to a heated incubator.
DR. T: There's, like, air
that's, like, blowing the heat,
so I think it's gonna
help her dry, actually,
without actually
blow-drying her.
NARRATOR:
And a few hours later,
she's ready to hit the road.
MARYANNE: That's it,
that's over, it's all done.
REBECCA: There you go, momma.
Hello, babe.
Who's cute? I love you.
For the last couple of months,
Shiloh has just been miserable.
I'm really looking forward to
having a happy, healthy bird,
and I'm very appreciative
to Dr. Thielen.
And so, I feel like she
not only saved Shiloh,
but she's given me
more tools to work with
so that it doesn't happen again.
Want to go home? We go bye-bye?
(squawk)
♪ ♪
DR. T: You're doing
a real good job, Molly.
NARRATOR: Molly,
the Flemish giant rabbit,
survived emergency surgery
to reinsert her bladder,
and now she's back for
a crucial follow-up exam.
DR. T: When Molly
arrived in the ER
with her bladder
literally hanging out,
Dr. Turner assessed her and
noticed that one of her ureters,
the tube that connects
the kidney to the bladder,
looked really inflamed
and potentially compromised.
So now that Molly's had
some time to recover,
we need to do an ultrasound
to make sure there's not
gonna be any long-term damage.
That's the bladder there?
DR. RAMIREZ: That's the bladder.
Very small.
DR. T: Yeah.
You don't see any free fluid
around it, so that's good.
DR. RAMIREZ: I don't.
DR. T: Molly's bladder
looks perfect,
so now we need to
investigate the ureters.
The notes from the ER commented
that one of the ureters
looked pretty traumatized,
so we're gonna check
both ureters,
just to make sure
everything looks okay.
My biggest concern here is that
if her ureter looks damaged,
we very likely could be dealing
with kidney damage, too,
and if that's the case,
we're looking at another surgery
and possible kidney removal.
DR. RAMIREZ: I don't know that
we will find a ureter
unless it's really huge.
There we go.
DR. T: There. Beautiful.
Molly's ureters look great, and
now we're on to the kidneys,
and hopefully they look
just as good.
DR. RAMIREZ: There's the kidney.
3.5 centimeters?
DR. T: Okay.
DR. RAMIREZ: Yeah, the
architecture of the right kidney
looks really pretty good.
Can we tilt her
a little bit towards me?
JENNIFER: Mm-hmm.
DR. RAMIREZ: Yeah, so we can
find that other kidney.
DR. RAMIREZ: There we go.
DR. T: There.
DR. RAMIREZ: It's the same.
It's the same size, okay, good.
DR. T: Good, perfect!
DR. RAMIREZ: I think
she got really lucky.
DR. T: That's great.
Good! Awesome.
Molly's ultrasound looks great!
The kidneys looked good,
and so at this point,
I'm going to check that problem
off our list,
and we're just gonna go ahead
and focus on her face.
NARRATOR: To solve the mystery
behind Molly's abscess,
Dr. T turns to skull x-rays
for clues.
TONYA: Let's do one more.
Pull everything back.
DR. T: Oftentimes in rabbits,
facial abscesses are
related to dental disease.
So, I really need to get some
good imaging to try to look
at Molly's teeth so we can get a
diagnosis and work on fixing it.
And by going over to dentistry,
I'll get the help
of Dr. Nossaman
who's a board-certified dentist.
If you just look at this x-ray,
you can see, like,
a little bit of asymmetry,
and what concerns me is
on this right lateral,
these two teeth right here.
I mean, I can tell you
these roots come too tall
and they're a little...
DR. NOSSAMAN: Deformed.
DR. T: Yeah, but I'm not
convinced I need to go in
and pull this rabbit's tooth.
I took my normal four view
skull x-rays as I always do,
and it's a little ambiguous.
I was expecting the tooth
to look horrible,
but it kind of doesn't.
Do you think an intra-oral x-ray
on a rabbit would work?
DR. NOSSAMAN: You could try.
DR. T: I don't do them often.
DR. NOSSAMAN: Yes.
DR. T: At this point, I really
need a specialized x-ray
so I can highlight just
the problematic area
and not be confused by
the rest of the skull.
If I take a dental x-ray,
I'm gonna be able to see
a much crisper, clearer image
and really nail down
that diagnosis.
DR. NOSSAMAN: There we go.
NARRATOR: And Molly's
dental x-rays give Dr. T
the answer she's
been digging for.
DR. T: Oh, yeah!
Look at that one tooth. Right?
DR. NOSSAMAN: This right here?
DR. T: Yes. Oh, my goodness!
DR. NOSSAMAN: Ahh. Good job!
DR. T: Taking a look
at the dental x-ray,
you can very clearly see
the tooth and the root,
and it's not healthy,
not normal.
NARRATOR: Molly's got
not just one, but two
extremely infected teeth.
DR. T: But look,
I mean, that's obvious.
HOLLIE: That's a huge abscess.
I saw it.
DR. T: You seen it.
She has these infected teeth.
We have to remove them,
there's no other option.
If we don't take care
of this infection,
then what could potentially
happen is the infection
can spread to the surrounding
teeth as well as the jaw.
NARRATOR: This means Molly
has to have another surgery,
and that doesn't come
without risks.
DR. T: Last time Molly
was anesthetized,
she died and had to be
brought back to life,
so the idea of having to
re-anesthetize her again
definitely scares me,
but we have no choice.
Alright, can I have
the anesthesia, please?
Unfortunately, the only way
for me to cure Molly's abscess
is to remove the infected teeth.
This poor little bunny
just has to get through
one more procedure.
DR. T: We are about to extract
two of her teeth.
Okely-dokely.
NARRATOR: Molly,
the Flemish giant rabbit,
has two severely
abscessed teeth,
and it's up to Dr. T to get
them out quickly and safely.
DR. T: So, rabbits' teeth
are squared,
so I have a much
different extractor
than a dog or a person
would use,
because I'm using
these flat surfaces
to get on each little corner
of the tooth, if you will.
So the key is to really
fatigue this ligament
that's holding
this tooth in place,
so I can get it really
nice and loose,
so when I extract it,
it doesn't break.
It's really, like,
in there, man.
Uh.
And there it is.
NARRATOR: One tooth out,
one to go.
DR. T: I love dentistry,
it's one of my favorite things,
especially rabbit dentistry.
I just find it really satisfying
'cause you can kind of
instantly cure them.
That's the gross one.
Ooh, look at the inside,
look at the inside.
You see it's hollow?
No, you don't appreciate it.
It's hollow inside.
DR. CROCKER:
I'll give him Meloxicam.
DR. T: It's hollow inside
and the pus is inside.
DR. CROCKER: Ooh, it's
completely eaten away.
DR. T: Isn't that cool?
I'm really happy to report
that rabbits don't miss
their infected teeth.
They haven't been using them
anyways, 'cause they hurt,
and so just taking them out
is one less thing
they have to worry about.
NARRATOR: A flush of her mouth
and some antibiotics later,
it looks like Molly's on
her way to a full recovery.
DR. T: Gonna put a little stitch
in her mouth and we'll be done.
So, suturing inside the mouth
is actually one of the most
difficult things
of the whole procedure,
'cause it's really small
and you have to get
these knots secured
and you have to sew
in this little tiny space.
Like, my fingers are small,
so I can theoretically get it,
but like, a man rabbit doctor,
like, I don't know
how he does it.
I'm gonna cut that knot
a little smaller.
That was awesome. All done.
Molly made it through
her dental surgery,
and by removing those
infected teeth,
we were able to cure
this abscess.
So now she's a much happier,
healthy bunny.
And even though we're all gonna
miss Molly at the hospital,
it's fantastic that
she gets to go home
to be with her loving family.
Yeah. Oh, she's so cute.
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: For every animal
that goes out the door,
another one comes in.
Last time Bandit and Boomer
were here to see Dr. T,
they had a little fun.
(screeching)
DR. T: No way! Tell me about it!
NARRATOR: But now that these
two sugar gliders
are a little older,
it's time to take care
of some serious business.
DR. T: They are now
finally big enough
that they can undergo anesthesia
and have their neuters.
Tonya and Maryanne both
are prepping these guys,
because I want a technician
to monitor
each one's anesthesia
individually,
so they can make sure that,
although we're doing
two surgeries kind of
simultaneously,
we're really safe.
DR. T: Oh, they're so cute.
Just look at them.
I really want some, guys.
TONYA: Sure.
You want a sugar glider?
DR. T: Yeah, I want two, and
then they can stay in a pouch
and I can see appointments
with them all day long
and they'll be my best friends.
I have to admit, they don't make
the best pet for everybody.
They're nocturnal,
they have like a musky odor,
they're really hyper
and they run around,
but I just find them
so adorable.
Okay, I'm gonna scrub it up
and do this thing.
A sugar glider neuter is a lot
different from other neuters
in the sense that,
because they're marsupials,
their scrotum is kind of unique.
It's actually above the penis
instead of below.
If you have it sitting
on the gauze,
I'm literally just gonna pick up
the testicle and cut it,
pick up the testicle and cut it,
and that's gonna be it.
Okay, so here we go.
This is a sterile cautery
that we're gonna use
in order to be able to not only
cut the skin and the vessels,
but also cauterize everything
to make sure it doesn't bleed.
NARRATOR: The procedure only
takes a hot minute.
DR. T: And that's it.
They're neutered.
Congratulations!
TONYA: Yay, guys.
DR. T: Woo! (laughs)
NARRATOR: And soon enough,
Bandit and Boomer are back up.
DR. T: Hello, hi, good morning.
How are you?
I know.
You got his little pouch?
Go back in here.
Okay, there you go, bye.
Perfect.
KIM: Hey!
DR. T: Hello.
They did really good.
KIM: Hi, Boomer.
DELAINEY: Hey, Boomer.
DR. T: Say hi, guys.
PRODUCER:
How are you guys feeling?
DELAINEY: Happy.
PRODUCER: Yeah,
why are you happy?
DELAINEY: Because they got fixed
and now they can be with
the other sugar gliders.
KIM: So we can put them
with the female
and not worry that
we're gonna have babies.
DELAINEY: He's peeing on me.
DR. T: Well,
he loves you so much.
Welcome to having sugar gliders.
I've been an exotic animal owner
my whole life.
We're probably
a little bit more crazy
than the average dog/cat owner,
but I love it,
and I love people who are
just super passionate
about their species
and want to do it right.
Captioned by
Side Door Media Services